طُرد جنرال روسي رفيع المستوى
لتحدثه علانية ضد حرب بوتين
أمام الجبهة الليلة للحصول على صوت رائع
لجنرال روسي في قيادة
القوات في جنوب أوكرانيا مباشرة على طول
خط المواجهة الحاسم بالقرب من زابارسيا ،
يقول الجنرال إنه أُعفي من الخدمة
لأنه يخبر الآن
الحقيقة حول ما يحدث بالفعل على
الخطوط الأمامية هنا هي الجنرال إيفان
بوبوف في شريط مخصص للجمهور الروسي ،
لذلك فقد أوجزت جميع
المشكلات الإشكالية الموجودة اليوم في الجيش من حيث
العمل القتالي والدعم الذي
أسميته الأشياء بأسمائها الحقيقية.  لفت الانتباه
إلى أهم مأساة Modern
Warfare وهي نقص
البطاريات المضادة للقتال وغياب
محطات استطلاع المدفعية
والأعماق الجماعية وإصابات إخواننا من
مدفعية العدو كما أثرت عددًا
من المشاكل الأخرى وعبرت عنها جميعًا
على الإطلاق.  أعلى مستوى بصراحة وقسوة
شديدة في المقابل ،
يبدو أن كبار القادة شعروا بنوع من
التهديد بداخلي وسرعان ما
أعدوا في يوم من الأيام أمرًا
وقع وزير الدفاع على الأمر وتخلص مني
فقط لإعطاء وجهة نظر
هنا.  الجنرال بوبوف ليس
قائدا عسكريا عاديا ، صحيح أنه
يقود أه كل تلك القوات في
الجنوب التي يتغذى عليها ليحظى بشعبية مع
قواته ويخبرهم أنه لشرف كبير
أن يقف معهم وهو يتعهد ببذل
كل ما في وسعه لتحقيق ذلك.  أسهل بالنسبة
لهم للقتال والعودة إلى الحياة
ثم واصل في هذا الصوت
اتهام القادة الروس طوال الطريق إلى
كبار القادة الروس بخيانة الجيش
كما قال العديد من قادة أفواج الفرق
اليوم أن جنود
القوات المسلحة الأوكرانية يمكنهم  لا
يخترق جيشنا من الجبهة ،
ضربنا قائدنا الكبير من
الخلف بشكل غادر وحيوي ، وقام
بقطع رأس الجيش في
أصعب لحظة وأعظم لحظة
استدعاء القيادة العليا لرؤسائه ،
واتهمهم التجار
بقطع رأس قواتهم بشكل حيوي ، إنه
لأمر مذهل أن نرى  لأن
الواقع هو أن الجنرال بوبوف والآخرون يعرفون
السعر الذي يمكن أن يكون عليه فقد يكون عاطلاً
عن العمل متأكدًا من أنه خارج الوظيفة التي
أقالها ولكنك تعلم أنه يمكن أن تكون
الأمور أسوأ بكثير قد تكون أسوأ بكثير
بالنسبة له لتحدثه  الحقيقة أننا لا
نعرف أنه لا يمكن تجاهل حقيقة أن
ضابطًا عسكريًا روسيًا كبيرًا واحدًا على الأقل ،
الجنرال سيرجي سيريفيكين ، الذي كان حليفًا
لرئيس فاغنر
الذي قاد التمرد المسلح
ضد بوتين جيدًا ،
لم يُشاهد منذ ذلك الحين.
قالت محاولة الانقلاب ومشرع روسي اليوم إن
سارة نباتية تقتبس القبض
جيدًا على عدد الجنرالات الروس الذين
لا يوافقون على حرب بوتين ،
إنه سؤال مهم يمكن أن يؤثر على
نتيجة هذه المعركة ويأتي
مع تزايد الغموض حول الحرب.
اغتيال قائد غواصة روسية
في الوقت الحالي ، أنت تشاهد
الفيديو الجديد المروع الذي لدينا وهو
يركض ستانيسلاف أريتسكي قبل لحظات فقط من
إطلاق النار عليه ، لذا يمكنك
رؤيته هناك وهو يركض وقد أطلق عليه الرصاص
وقتل عدة مرات بعد ثوانٍ ،
يمكنك أن ترى  رجل يرتدي ما يبدو أنه
قبعة بيضاء تتبعه الآن ، يبدو
أن قاتل أرويتسكي كان بإمكانه
تتبع تحركاته باستخدام
تطبيق الجري الشهير المسمى سترافا الآن ،
حصلنا عليه هنا في المناصب الأمامية
لمرورتي أريتسكي السابقة إلى هذا المكان
حيث تم إطلاق النار عليه  سقط وقتل
من 3 يوليو و 5 يوليو قبل خمسة أيام من
مقتله وانظر إلى الخريطة ،
الخريطة متطابقة يسلك نفس
الطريق في كل مرة ، وكان هذا الطريق طويلًا جدًا
حيث قتل أريتسكي
نيك بيتون والش يتابع كل
هذه التطورات في الصدارة
الليلة ، ولنبدأ نيك بالأخبار
العاجلة ، هذا الشريط الذي
حصلنا عليه عن جنرال روسي طُرد بسبب
التحدث علانية ضد جنرال روسي كبير في حرب بوتين
على تلك الخطوط الأمامية الحاسمة
في الجنوب على طول جوبارشا ، من
الصعب المبالغة في تقديره.  ما مدى أهمية هذا
التطور
حقًا ، وعليك أن تضعه
في سياق
الأسابيع الثلاثة الماضية الرائعة داخل جيش بوتين ، لقد
كان لدينا للتو
مجموعة مرتزقة مسلحة من فاجنر ، نعم ، ولكن
بشكل أساسي تغذيها شكاوى مماثلة جدًا
حول روسيا بشكل أساسي
خسارة حرب المدفعية في الخطوط الأمامية الرئيسية
كما كان إيفان بوبوف يصنع ، باستثناء
بوبوف ، يتحدث جنرال من داخل كبار
الضباط الروس مرة أخرى عن
سوء سلوكهم وسوء تنفيذهم لهذه
الحرب وقد تحدث وفقد
وظيفته بسرعة كبيرة الآن أعتقد هذا هو
علامة أخرى على الفوضى
التي رأيناها تتسرب بعد
تمرد واغنر وتأتي في غضون
48 ساعة غريبة بالفعل لكبار
الضباط الروس حيث رأينا اغتيالات رفيعة المستوى
داخل أعماق القادة الروس الذين
قتلوا في الضربات الصاروخية
والآن هذا غير عادي  الانحدار من
بوبوف ، هذا ما نعرفه
للجنرالات الروس أن المنزل الذي كان
بعيدًا جدًا عن الجبهة لم يعد آمنًا
هنا يقود الغواصة الروسية السابق
ستانيسلاف رزيتسكي طريقه المعتاد
في الوقت المعتاد ، لكن مع
رفيق جديد لم يلاحظه أحد على دراجة بعد لحظات.
قالت مخابرات الدفاع الأوكرانية إنها
لا علاقة لها بالأمر لكنهم يعرفون
الكثير عنها قائلين إن إطلاق النار عليه
سبع مرات بمسدس ماكاروف وإن
الأمطار الغزيرة تعني عدم وجود شهود
بريزيزيتسكي قاد غواصة روسية
متهمة بارتكاب العديد من الهجمات على المدنيين
أوكرانيا أيضا  على الرغم من أن عائلته
نفت أن أوكرانيا أضافت
لاحقًا ربما بسخرية أنه
قُتل على يد رجاله الذين رفضوا
قتل المدنيين الأوكرانيين ،
سارعت روسيا بالرد
بدعاية خاصة بها مدعية أنها ألقت القبض على
المسلح في غضون ساعات بالفيديو الذي لا يمكننا
التحقق منه  لكنها كانت محاولة فجة لإثبات
أنهم يتحكمون في مصير كبار
ضباطهم بعد أسابيع من الفوضى.
تاريخ طويل من
الكشف عن غير قصد عن أماكن
الأشخاص الذين لا يريدون أن يتم العثور عليهم ،
وكشفوا عن وجود قواعد عسكرية أمريكية في سوريا
واليمن قبل خمس سنوات ،
هناك قتلى وأيضًا
الأخبار المفقودة يوم الأربعاء 2 حول هذا الملازم الرئيس بوتين
سيرجي سورا اختفت
منذ ذلك الحين  ظهر في وقت مبكر من
تمرد فاجنر المسلح لمناشدة من أجل إيقافه ،
ادعى مشرع روسي كبير أنه كان
يقتبس ما يعنيه ذلك مما يعني
المزيد من الغموض الذي يضيف إلى أكبر
شخصية عسكرية في روسيا ، زعيم تمرد واغنر
يفغيني براغوسيان الذي لم يسبق له مثيل منذ
نهاية الأسبوع.  تمرد على الرغم من ادعاءات الكرملين أنه
التقى ببوتين بعد أيام وتعهد بانقلاب
مفاجئ واستمرار الولاء
[موسيقى]
الركض الميت أو ما زال يضيع
وقتًا مضطربًا في كبار الضباط
الآن ، من المهم إيريك أن نضيف أننا حصلنا
اليوم على تأكيد من وسائل الإعلام الحكومية الروسية
بأن  قُتل قائد رئيسي آخر مرة
أخرى في الجنوب ، اللفتنانت جنرال
أوليغ سوكوف ، على ما يبدو
بصاروخ بعيد المدى ألقى
المدونون الروس باللوم عليه على
صواريخ ستورم شادو التي زودتها بريطانيا ، وهذا مرة
أخرى هو قائد آخر
لأسباب مختلفة فجأة ليس في موقعهم في
معظم الأحيان  جزء حيوي من المنطقة التي
تدافع عنها روسيا من
الجاني المضاد المستمر لأوكرانيا الذي
يسير بخطى هذه المغادرين سيكون
له تأثير تكتيكي بغض النظر عن مدى
سرعة استبدال هؤلاء الأشخاص بالأمس ،
وضعت وزارة الدفاع الروسية
وجهاً شجاعًا عندما قالت إن
تسليم فاجنر.  2000 قطعة من معدات
الدبابات والمدفعية وما إلى ذلك ، لكن ما
نراه هنا حقًا هو
نزول متزايد من الجمهور ، وهو أمر
نادر للغاية سيضر بالمعنويات
ولكن على الأرجح سيضر
بأداء روسيا في الأماكن التي يحتاجون إليها
للقتال بشدة  هارون